okay let's get started so today we'll be
covering Bayesian meta learning
algorithms and just first rehearsing
with this tics homework two came out
last Wednesday and is due next week on
Wednesday
I'm your project proposal is due two
weeks from today and so if you don't
have a clear idea for who your group is
going to be if you're gonna work alone
what your project is gonna be the media
encourage you to come to office hours
and discuss that or post on Piazza or
email one of us also we determined a we
kind of set in stone at a date and time
and location for the poster presentation
it will be on Tuesday December 3rd at
1:30 p.m. and we expect for all
on-campus students to have at least one
group member present the poster session
for at least it's part of it such that
you can kind of present your work to the
broader AI and machine learning
community at Stanford okay so let's get
started with the lecture and I first
like to start with a couple disclaimers
the first is that Bayesian meta learning
is a very active area of research and
something that's even more active than
other parts of this course and so there
may be more questions than answers in
terms of the particular algorithms that
we have but at the same time this makes
it a pretty exciting topic because
there's I think there's a lot of room
for better algorithms and better ways to
be thinking about how to evaluate these
algorithms and then the second
disclaimer is that this lecture probably
covers some of the most advanced topics
of this course and so I'll try to go
slowly through through some of the
technical content and I guess due to
both of these please ask questions if
things aren't aren't clear and I'll try
to also go through the relevant
background material with regard to
Bayesian neural networks for example
okay so let's get started by recapping
the things that we talked about last
time so we had covered different meta
learning approaches and also a couple
unified ways to think about these
different meta learning approaches so
the first perspective was this
computation graph perspective where we
looked at all of these different meta
learning algorithms as as different
computation graphs some that are
completely black box some that have
gradient operators
optimization procedures embedded inside
of them and some that use nonparametric
algorithms kind of embedded inside of it
as well so this is kind of one way of
thinking about meta learning algorithms
as a function that takes in the data set
and it's a test input and makes a
prediction about a new input about that
input and then second we also talked
about an algorithmic properties
perspective of these methods which is
that what sort of properties do these
algorithms have and what are kind of the
trade-offs between these different
properties so we talked about expressive
power basically the ability for these
functions to represent a wide range of
learning procedures or a wide range of
functions of the data set that's being
passed as input we also talked about
consistency which is that given enough
data these algorithms will produce an
answer that you're satisfied with and
these important these property both of
these properties are very important and
the third property that we haven't
really talked about much so far is this
concept of uncertainty awareness and
that's what we'll be covering today
we're on certainty awareness is the
ability to reason about ambiguities
during the learning process the ability
to reason about whether or not whether
or not the kind of it's very clear what
the function is or whether or not you
should have uncertainty about the
underlying function that your data is
providing evidence for so why is this
important well motivate this a bit more
in more detail but at a high level the
reason why we care about this is that it
allows us to think about active learning
about explicitly reducing our
uncertainty if we have uncertainty about
our function it also wants us think
about how we might explore new
environments in a reinforcement learning
context in order to reduce our
uncertainty but also thinks about if
we're in safety critical settings we
want to calibrate uncertainty estimates
that's also pretty important and it also
makes us think about from the Bayesian
perspective of medal earning what sort
of principal approaches can be derived
from those graphical models okay so
that's all be covering today at a high
level we'll talk about first go into
more detail about why why it makes sense
to Bayesian and kind of set up the
framework for which we'll be talking
about then we'll talk about different
metal or different Bayesian learning
in the context of the different
algorithms that we've discussed in this
course so far and then lastly we'll talk
about how we can evaluate a bayesian
meta learning algorithm and the
different types of ways these meta
learning algorithms might be useful in
practice okay good so that's the plan
let's first talk about some motivation
so the beauty of this course we talked
about some principles behind multitask
learning and meta learning and one of
the first principles we talked about is
that is kind of a basic principle of
machine learning which is that training
and testing must match and if the
conditions that that you're if the
conditions that you see at test time or
not matching the conditions that you're
training for then you won't necessarily
expect the ability to generalize or the
ability to learn a new task and then the
second principle that we talked about
was that the task must share some sort
of structure I without the structure you
won't get any benefit from sharing
across the tasks and this is the point
that I'd like to go in a little bit more
depth on which is that what does
structure even mean and I think that one
way that we could actually try to
formally define what structure means
here is that there's some statistical
dependence on some shards latent
information across the tasks and
particularly what we can do is we can
bring up this graphical model which I've
showed in a few lectures ago where theta
is the kind of the meta parameters that
are shared across all tasks Phii is the
task specific parameters for each task I
and then we also have a number of data
points in X PI J for each of the AI
tasks and in particular in this
graphical model you can see that there
is some dependence on theta
basically there's each of the each of
the the parameters by I have an arrow
coming from theta and in particular if
you condition on the information in
theta we know first that the task
parameters become independent that is
Phi Phi I is independent of another Phi
I condition on theta and if you don't
condition on theta on the lane
information then they're not otherwise
independent and in particular if you
then look at these two properties which
is that they're not independent without
any conditioning information and they're
and they're independent once you
condition then you can say that you the
distribution over Phi given theta is
going to have lower entropy than the
distribution of the marginal of v
essentially theta tells you information
about your Kasper it stopped specific
parameters Phi oh okay
this all makes sense so I always like to
give you a thought exercise which is
that if you can identify theta for
example through metal Ernie if you can
identify what's shared across the tasks
in what situations should it be faster
to learn v in compared to learning from
scratch are there any thoughts on that
or maybe I can rephrase the question in
which situations would it not be faster
than learning from scratch yeah yeah
that's a good point so yeah exactly so
if the if the first entropy is much much
smaller then the data basically tells
you a lot about the task and it should
be much faster to learn than just
learning from scratch because learning
from scratch feel but just be looking at
five was there another
can you repeat that yeah exactly so
that's also true
so if basically if they are if they're
independent before knowing conditioning
on theta then basically these n trapeze
will be the same and then learning from
scratch will be just as just as fast as
learning from the shared information
theta any other thoughts on this
so what additional point that's I guess
worth mentioning is that if if a single
data point carries all of the
information of theta like maybe your
tasks correspond to all possible image
classification tasks sampled at random
and the fact that you see a single data
point like an image it being an image
that doesn't really tell you that much
or the image kind of that basically the
the certain information doesn't tell you
that much because that information is
also exists in a single data point which
is that as an image classification task
and in those situations first the the
entropy conditioned on theta is going to
be fairly high as well as the marginal
entropy and the and also that kind of
thinking about how this compares to the
entropy condition on one data point
versus a large number of data points ok
one of the thought exercise what if the
entropy of Phi given theta is zero what
would happen in that case
or what what situation does not describe
yeah so we don't even need to learn Phi
if basically they're the same then or if
if base if there isn't any additional
information in Phi that isn't captured
in theta then theta I can solve all of
the tasks and you don't need to do
anything to learn from data okay so
these are kind of interesting properties
to think about for example if you're in
this last in this law setting if you can
basically learn a single
parameters that captures all of their
tasks and you don't need to necessarily
do any learning in order to adapt to new
tasks and you can just basically use
that single parameter vector for solving
the details okay so what information
might theta contain we talked about this
a bit earlier in the lecture or earlier
in the course but one thing kind of
reiterate here is if you look at kind of
a couple examples of the that we saw
earlier in the course for example this
twice I have a problem that we saw in
some of the student presentations last
week what information would theta
contain in in this task family
any thoughts
yeah yeah so if the basically if this if
the family of tasks corresponds to
sinusoids with different amplitude in
different faiths then theta will
correspond to that exact that family of
sinusoid functions right and it'll
basically correspond to everything but
the phase and amplitude which is the
task specific information that needs to
be inferred from data in this example
and further if you look at the the
language translation case that was
presented a couple weeks ago in this
machine translation example theta is
going to correspond to all possible
language pairs data and the information
in Phi that isn't present in theta is
going to correspond to things that are
specific to a particular language okay
um and note that in both of these
examples theta is narrower than the
space of all possible functions and this
because of this this is why we can get a
benefit from using things like mendler
ting in principle okay
the last exercise that we also haven't
really talked about much in this course
is what if you meta learn without a lot
of tasks so if you have an infinite
number of tasks you can you should be
able to recover theta exactly or
basically recover kind of that family
with high precision what if you don't
have a lot of tasks what happens then
sorry what what do you mean by that you
mean make more tasks yeah so if you
don't have if you don't have a lot of
tosses you should definitely you should
it's good to try to make more tasks if
you can't make more tasks what happens
mm-hmm yeah so it'll yeah so what it
will do is if you have kind of a space
of tasks it won't necessarily cover the
true distribution of tasks but will
potentially over fit or what I would
call meta over-fitting to that space of
tasks such that actually doesn't recover
theta that corresponds to for example
all language pairs but it will court
find a theta that corresponds to a set
of language pairs that looks like the
things in your training data and not
something that captures the full
distribution and then as a result you
won't be as effective at adapting to new
things from that distribution from the
broader distribution unless they're very
close to the training examples so it's
basically a form of overfitting that's
lifted and not from data points but two
tasks okay so here are a couple examples
of I think how it's how Bayesian meta
learning or this graphical model at
least helps us think about these
different properties of metal learning
algorithms and different things that
will happen if you train in different
situations now a bit more motivation
here so that was kind of motivation at
the conceptual level what about in
practice so so far we've looked at
parametric approaches and nonparametric
approaches but for the parametric
approaches what we recovered was the
deterministic estimate of the task
specific parameters v given the data set
and your meta parameters data so you
just actually get a point estimate for
this distribution right here so this is
it seemed to work fine on your homework
you implemented this and you perfect
presumably got decent performance out of
this what is this a problem or or why is
this a problem
well there are a few Scituate there are
some situations where we need more than
just a point estimate so for example
sudden future learning problems may not
be fully determined by their data and in
particular because you're in the future
learning
and maybe that the underlying function
is ambiguous given the evidence that you
have and your prior information so as an
example of this say you have 10 examples
5 positives and 5 negatives and your
goal is to classify between between
these two the two binary classification
problem between these these two classes
and in particular all the images on the
left are people that are smiling people
that are wearing a hat and people that
are young and all the people on the
right are people that are not smiling
not wearing a hat and not young and then
if you get a new test image of someone
who is smiling and wearing a hat and not
young the underlying function or the
underlying label for this particular
image isn't it is inherently ambiguous
we don't know if we're supposed to be
classifying with regard to smiling with
regard to wearing a hat with regard to
being young or any pair of these
attributes and forget we can also look
at another example where someone is
wearing a hat and young but not smiling
so inherently the kind of the answer to
the correct label for these images is
ambiguous because the data set was so
small okay so to try to reconcile this
problem what if we can generate
hypotheses about the underlying function
so what if we can sample from this
distribution if we can sample from this
distribution then we can reason about
our uncertainty we can then kind of
reason about basically whether or not
we're going to be able to make an
effective and accurate decision in the
situation which is really important in
safety critical settings it can allow us
to explicitly reduce her and certainty
because we can get some measure of of
which examples have high uncertainty in
which examples have low uncertainty and
then we can try to ask for labels from
the from some user and there's been a
number of works that have looked at this
and also one of the presentations on
Wednesday is I think believe the third
paper here which we'll be covering I
specifically meta learning approaches
for active learning and Leslie it'll be
important for learning to explore in
metal reinforcement learning which we'll
cover in a couple lectures
so at the can the bare minimum we want
to be able to sample from this
distribution we also may want to try to
generate try to be able to do other
things like evaluate the likelihood of a
function or to be able to measure like
the entropy of this distribution for
example okay so that's kind of the
motivation for Bayesian metal learning
algorithms any questions before I move
on to the particular methods that people
use yeah yeah
so for active learning if you have an
estimate of basically your ear
confidence or your uncertainty regarding
a particular example like for example in
these if you have if you're trying to
acquire a more accurate classifier in
this setting and you have some examples
that look like this and some examples
that look like these ones on the left
then you should the kind of the correct
thing to do is to ask for a label for
the ones that you are uncertain about
and such that you can explicitly try to
reduce your uncertainty about the
underlying function and so these types
of uncertainty estimates give you a
means to reason about that okay
so let's start talking about some
approaches for being able to sample from
this distribution or be able to
basically being able to represent our
uncertainty so the first simplest
approach that we'll talk about is
something that could actually be applied
to all three classes of metal aring
algorithms and in particular if we care
about generating a distribution over our
predictions one thing that we could do
is just let our function f output the
parameters of a distribution over our
label so for example you could have any
of these functions F from kind of the
computational graph perspective output
something that corresponds to the
probability of a discrete categorical
distribution if your label Y is discrete
or if you can make it discrete I could
also you can also output the mean and
variance of the Gaussian distribution
to represent I got from distribution up
for your labels or if you have a more
multimodal distribution you could try to
represent the means and variances and
mixture weights of a mixture of
gaussians or if you want to do something
more sophisticated if you have a
multi-dimensional output label Y then
you could output the parameters of a
sequence of distributions a sequence of
conditional distributions to allow you
to represent the Joint Distribution over
those variables and this would be what's
called an auto regressive model and once
you output the parameters of a
distribution you can then train any of
these approaches with the maximum
likelihood estimate optimizing both over
the mean of the distribution as well as
the variance or basically all the full
probability values of that distribution
okay so this is really simple and this
is and for example if you do mean
squared error for example that
corresponds to optimizing for the mean
of a Gaussian but not the variance for
the variance corresponds to a identity
matrix so and then you actually are sort
of already implicitly getting a
distribution yeah yeah exactly so in the
first case the cross entropy lost
corresponds to maximizing the likelihood
of doing maximum likelihood with a
categorical distribution so in
classification examples that we're
already doing that in principle this
should give you reasonable uncertainty
estimates in practice I guess this is
I'll get into the pros and cons in a
second but in practice doing that
doesn't necessarily give you good good
calibrated uncertainty estimates and the
and neural networks for example in
general tend to be a bit overconfident
in their predictions okay so this is a
very simple approach the benefit is that
it's simple and you can combine it with
a variety of methods downsides
first is that it doesn't always lead to
accurate uncertainty estimates which I
actually didn't write down on the slide
but that certainly
one of the downsides another downside is
you can't reason about uncertainty about
the underlying function just the
uncertainty about the individual data
points and so for example you you can't
disentangle model uncertainty versus
label noise for example and is also
limited to a particular class of
distributions over Y and in some of the
following slides will look at more
expressive classes of distributions
where we can represent more basically
distributions over the functions fairly
expressively okay so this is version 0
now the first month downside here is
that we can't reason about the
uncertainty about the underlying
function so one very natural thing to
think is well can we just remark
somewhat the same maximum likelihood
training but over the model parameters
Phi so does anyone want to comment on
why we could how we could do this or how
we couldn't do this
hmm yeah so we could have our our neural
network output a like a mean and
variance for each of the parameters in
PI and how would we if we did that say
we did that how would we go about
training the the training our model to
output that distribution
I see so you're basically saying that we
could like I see so how would you get
how when you say you train them but do
you mean by training the OSE so you're
saying that you train the parameters
five for given tasks see where it ends
up and then so basically that would
correspond to something like you kind of
run gradient descent on for given tasks
see what the or SGD or something see
what the mean and the variance are and
then use that to try to fit your fitness
at this estimator yeah so it'd be an
interesting approach I don't know if I
don't think anyone has done anything
like that before but it'd be interesting
to see yeah yeah there you go
any other thoughts yeah
yeah so you can't so we can't do it
exactly the same way as we did for the
top one because we don't have labels
corresponding to fight unless we
generated labels like Samuel is saying
so yeah so it's an interesting thought
exercise to think about and we'll talk
about basically different ways that we
can get we can get we can basically
train for this
without having to have labels for the
particular parameters that we that we
get okay so before I go into the
different approaches I want to give a
kind of a one slide overview of the
Bayesian deep learning toolbox which is
kind of the overview the different types
of techniques we have available to us
for combining Bayesian graphical models
and deep learning it's worth mentioning
that cs2 36 provides an entire course on
this topic and so one slide is by no
means gives it justice it's a very calm
very there's been a lot of work in this
area but I think that this will be
important for thinking about how we can
build Bayesian learning algorithms on
the next few slides okay
so the general goal of these types of
approaches is to think about how we can
represent distributions using neural
networks and there's been a number of
approaches for doing this and one of the
most popular approaches are a very
popular approach is to use latent
variable models and then optimize them
with variational inference and so in
particular what this corresponds to is
we have a graphical model or something
like a graphical model on the right
where we have latent variable Z and
observe variables X this is the
graphical model for example for a
variational auto encoder and then what
you do is you can optimize you can
optimize for a distribution over X using
the variational lower bound of you
basically formulate a little
round of the likelihood objective and
use that to optimizer for a distribution
over X where that dissipation of X may
be non Gaussian because it has this
latent variable and I'll go into a
little bit more depth on this approach
in a few minutes okay
another approach that has been fairly
popular in some regard and it's quite
simple is to use a particle based
representation of your of your
distribution and in particular what you
can do is you can train separate models
on different bootstraps of your data and
then get each of those models will
correspond to a particle of your
distribution and then you get kind of
this you basically to gather those
particles represent samples from that
distribution so this is something that
could be useful is it's pretty simple to
come pretty easy to combine with
different types of algorithms another
approach which has been somewhat eluded
to is to represent an explicit
distribution over the weights of neural
network parameters and practice these
distributions tend to be Gaussian with
an independent a diagonal covariance
matrix so you have basically an
independent variance for each narrow
Network parameter and this allows you to
represent a distribution of our
functions with the caveat that this
independence assumption that two
parameters are independent is violated
in practice basically all the time
there's also things like normalizing
flows that try to that represent a
function of over over a data
distribution by inverting some latent
distribution into your data distribution
or transforming from latent space into
your data space and back into your
latent space and these these have been
pretty successful for current wide range
of applications and mostly is energy
based models and to some approximation
gans
and what these types of models do is
they tend to estimate a normalized
density where you have some probability
that you want some probability over your
data that you want to represent and the
way that you do that is you push down
energy to have lower energy for your
data and higher energy for everything
else where everything else is
approximated by your generator and again
or something like that yeah so these are
the two so this is kind of an overview
of the general types of think tools that
we have in in deep learning to be able
to represent distributions over data and
over functions in this lecture we'll see
how we can leverage the first two on
this list for metal learning approaches
the others could certainly also be
useful in developing new Bayesian
learning methods to my knowledge people
haven't looked at these types of
approaches in the context of Bayesian
metal learning but they could certainly
be be interesting for developing new
methods okay great so that was I guess
for those of you that haven't seen this
content before that was a lot faster
than then you probably would need to to
learn these sorts of things of course
but this is just but the goal of this so
first we're gonna look at how we can use
latent variable models in the context of
metal earning and you just I want to
give it a little bit more background on
variational techniques and latent
variable models in deep learning in a
particular this is the graphical model
that we'll be looking at this is the
graphical model that's used in in
variational auto-encoders where X is
typically representing the data and Z is
representing your latent variables but
in many graphical model is more general
than just representing distributions
over your data I will see that on the
next slide but I'll kind of derive
things from the context of this
graphical model because it's a very
general graphical model corresponding to
things that are observed and latent
variables that we want to be able to
reason about okay
so in this example the observed variable
is X and our latent variable is Z again
these could be this could be data and
and something late and information
recalls to be X could also represent
something else and what prior
paperwork's have done is
I've a lower bound to the likelihood of
our data which is called the evidence
lower bound or the elbow and this looks
like this so the we want to be able to
estimate a lower bound on the likelihood
of our data this is so that we can
optimize for the likelihood of our data
and we can represent this by what showed
on the right here which is the
expectation with respect to Q of Z given
X what Q is representing the variational
distribution of the probability of X and
Z plus an entropy term that is
regularizing or operating on Q of Z
given X how many people I guess how many
people are familiar with kind of the
background of how you get this equation
okay and how many people would find it
useful to actually go through how we get
this equation okay let's do that it's
not it's actually not that so we have
some we're starting with the log
likelihood of our of our data and we
also have some some codes it looks like
so we want to be able to approximate
this where X is our observed variable
and the reason why we want to do this is
typically we want to be able to maximize
the likelihood of our data with respect
to some parameters of our model such
that we can maximize the likelihood of
things that we're observing so what
we're going to first do is under that
graphical model we can say that this is
simply the integral over some latent
variable the Joint Distribution of our
observed variable and our latent
variable Z this is fairly
straightforward and then what we're
gonna do here is we're going to
introduce a what's called a variational
distribution this is can this can be any
really any arbitrary distribution and
we're going to introduce it like this so
we're just going to
multiply it in and divide it out no
cubes you can really is some arbitrary
distribution we'll talk about exactly
how we instantiate it and how we can
optimize for it such that we get a
tighter bound later this is equal to so
if you basically bring this term over
here you can see that we're getting in
we can get an expectation with respect
to Q so this is equal to an expectation
with respect to Q of Z of P of X comma Z
divided by oh I missing the log here
sorry okay and then one week what we can
do here is that with Jensen's inequality
we can show that this we can basically
bring the log into the expectation and
we get a bound which corresponds to an
expectation with respect to Q of Z of
log P of X comma Z minus log Q of Z okay
and then from here we basically get
what's written on the board so this is
equal to expectation of Q of Z times log
P of X comma Z plus the entropy of Q of
Z cool
I mentioned that Q of Z is can be any
arbitrary distribution that means we can
also condition Q of Z on X as is done on
the slides yeah alright any questions on
on how this works yes that's a typo
there should be a log basically inside
the P of X inside the expectation I'll
fix that
before I alpha excited update the slides
I made these equations like yesterday so
that's why there's like a couple type of
okay and this could also be this is
probably a typo in the next one - yeah
there's also type on the next one so
this could also be re-written as you can
basically take out you can represent
this as log P of X given Z times P of Z
and with this you can then bring this
term in to combine this term with the
entropy term here and you get a KL
divergence between Q and P and so this
might be the if you're familiar with
variational autoencoders you may see
this term a bit more frequently where
the first term corresponds to the
reconstruction loss of your decoder
basically the likelihood of your data
according to decoder after sampling from
your inference Network q and the second
term corresponds to the KL divergence
between your inference network and your
prior okay so he corresponds to your
model and Q corresponds to this kind of
variational distribution that we
introduced in order to approximate the
likelihood objective and so then we have
a couple couple of things that a couple
design choices so the first design
choice is how do we represent P of Z and
the second choice is how do we represent
P of X given Z these are kind of the two
the two parts of this of the model and P
of x given Z can be represented as a
neural network so in the case of a
variational auto-encoder P of X given Z
corresponds to a neural network that
takes in your latent variable and
outputs an image or whatever your
whatever data type you're modeling and
then P of Z is represented as a is
typically represented as just a diagonal
Gaussian with unit variance you can also
learn your prior P of Z could also be
represent
by a neural network as well or
represented as a learned mean and a
learned variance in practice in
variational autoencoders you typically
don't learn it because the layer
afterward can transform it into a
learned mean invariance but we'll see in
in the meta learning case they're
actually gonna be situations where I'll
want to learn it okay and then cube z
given x is also represented by a neural
network this is also often referred to
as your inference network or your
variational distribution okay and then
to connect to the graphical model a bit
typically in in when using variational
inference in the context of deep
learning you often use theta to
represent your model parameters and Phi
to represent the parameters of your
inference Network
I dropped these in all of these
equations because we're gonna be using
theta and Phi to represent different
things as you might imagine on the
following slides okay so this is all
nice we have an objective we could
optimize we have kind of neural networks
that are representing different
components of this I began just back
propagate our objective into our neural
networks yeah yes exactly yeah
so the solid arrows are representing the
the model distribution and the - arrows
are representing the variational
distribution okay so we have an
objective oh we should be able to
optimize it right but we have a problem
the problem is that we have an
expectation with respect to Q and we
need to be able to back propagate into
this Q distribution and sampling
unfortunately is not differentiable so
one of the kind of tricks that has been
actually pretty critical to making these
making this type of approach work in the
context of neural networks is what's
called the Reeb parameterization trick
and in particular what we can show is
that for a Gaussian Q of Z given X you
can represent qu z given x in a differ
way that is kind of Reaper amortized in
terms of this noise that is sampled from
a unit Gaussian so in particular if
we're representing the distribution of
our latent variable as a Gaussian which
corresponds to the output of this neural
network Q which is outputting both a
mean and a variance then you can
represent the output of that neural
network as kind of being reprioritized
by this noise rather than sampling from
that particular distribution of the mean
plus the variance times that noise and
fortunately this equation is something
that's differentiable we can
differentiate with respect to this for
this equation with respect to the mean
and the variance parameters into the
parameters of Q into the parameters of
that neural network okay so this is
something special that you can do for
captions I believe there's also some
work that has looked at non Gaussian
distributions as well although in
practice I think that the kind of the
easiest thing to do is is to do it with
the options and if your inference
network is expressive enough it should
be able to transform your your day
distribution into this Gaussian
distribution over latent variables okay
so that was a primer on variational
inference for deep learning any
questions before I move on to how we can
use this with my learning okay also I
guess worth mentioning this is often
called amortized variational inference
in that we're having an inference
network that's that's predicting what
the variational distribution will be is
basically amortize in the process of
estimating that distribution
there are also variational inference
techniques that I estimate this
distribution of Rosi by using something
like MCMC for example by by optimizing
with respect to your your likelihood so
can we use amortize variational
inference for metal earning so first
let's think about blackbox metal
learning approaches first simplicity and
in particular what we want to be able to
do is have a neural network that takes
us and put a train data set and produces
a distribution over our
parameters volume and then we're gonna
take our parameters Phi and have that
parameterize a neural network that takes
us input X and outputs Y okay so in the
standard via e our observed variables X
our latent variable Z and we kind of
derived what the what the lower bound of
our likelihood is in the middle learning
case our observed variable is our data
and our latent variable is our
parameters Phi and so what we can do is
we can basically use everything that we
derived here in for basically meta
learning where the latent variable is
now going to be Phi and in particular
what we can do is we can take take the
elbow written above again sorry for the
lack of logs on the left oh I'll fix
that typo we get basically something
that looks like we'll have a variational
distribution over our TAS specific
parameters Phi will sample from that
distribution and estimate the likelihood
of our data given Phi and then we'll
have this KL term that's saying that the
variational distribution and our our
prior over Phi should be similar okay so
this is pretty simple there's a couple
design decisions so the first design
decision is what should q conditioned on
in this case the if we want to be able
to sample parameters so if you basically
I guess I sort of gave it away in the
top left if you want to be able sampled
parameters as a function of our data set
then we should condition Q on our
training data all right so that's
exactly what we'll do here and also one
question is how does this training data
differ from the the probability of our
data used here and what we'll use for
the data here will correspond to our
test data points so you want to be able
to maximize the likelihood of the test
data points given our top specific
parameters when sampling our task
specific parameters as a function of our
changes
okay that's gonna be what every star it
looks like and what our what our
objective looks like what about the meta
parameters so we're missing the meta
parameters right now they don't appear
anywhere and that's because they didn't
actually give any parameters to P and Q
so the meta parameters will come in is
that they'll be parameters of our model
so I added here basically we'll have our
prior over our pass Pacific parameters v
be conditioned on theta although you
could also have a prior that corresponds
to like a unit variance or something but
if you condition on data you might get a
bit more expressive power and then we'll
also condition our inference that work
on theta as well because well basically
theta will correspond to the kind of the
parameters of our inference Network one
other thing worth mentioning in this
case this the distribution over our test
data points is a function of only five
you could also conditional on theta here
and that will correspond to something
that's a bit more like what you
implement in your homework where the
where Phi is something that's like a low
dimensional vector and theta is
representing like the parameters of a
neural network okay so for completeness
our final objective is written down here
where we're gonna have and again I'm
missing the log in front of the P but
we're gonna be maximizing with respect
to our meta parameters and expectation
over all of our tasks and then we'll
sample task specific parameters from
from our neural network Q use those to
maximize the likelihood of P and then
we'll also have this term on the right
that encourages Q to stay close to some
prior distribution note that if you drop
this right Kayle term we get something
that looks basically exactly like what
we've been optimizing before this right
Cale term is what actually ensures that
it corresponds to a distribution and
that we're actually maximizing a lower
bound on the likelihood and
so what the variational inference buys
you is it ensures that Q is out is it's
going to be outputting a proper
distribution over Phi and so if you only
did maximum likelihood over the labels
then you will get a distribution over Y
but you won't necessarily be guaranteed
that the distribution over Phi is
actually a proper distribution is
actually like something that represents
the true distribution over your over
your latent parameter over your light
and toss parameters does that make sense
yes it corresponds to the elbow of the
evidence lower bound of the the observed
variables in that graphical model yes
basically yeah to me what it buys you is
that you can represent a distribution
over Phi and nothing more than that oh I
guess oh the last thing it does give you
also sorry is you can represent non
Gaussian distributions over Y now or not
like if Y is continuous for example this
because we're introducing a latent
variable the this distribution condition
on Phi it will it needs to be a Scotian
or something but because you're
introducing this latent variable now
because it's conditioned on Phi this the
marginal distribution of Y given X can
be something that's highly multimodal
can be be really anything anything that
can be represented that can be
transformed from a Gaussian to another
distribution by a neural network okay
cool so there's our objective the
benefits of this approach is that you
can represent non Gaussian distributions
over Y and you can also get a
distribution I didn't write this we can
get a distribution over your task
parameters Phi rather than only getting
a distribution over your labels so this
allows you to represent over about your
uncertainty over the underlying function
and not just about the underlying data
points the downside is that this can
only represent Gaussian distributions of
PFI given theta and that's if there's I
guess two reasons for that one is the
reprioritization trick which you can
which holds forgotten got some
distributions but as much more difficult
to do for non Gaussian distributions the
second thing is that the the ko term
that comes up in the objective is
something that can be evaluated in
closed form for gaussians but can't be
evaluated in closed form for other non
Gaussian objectives okay I mean the
second thing is is a downside
particularly if Phi is representing all
of the parameters of a neural network if
if this distribution is also conditional
on theta and for example you did
something in your homework where Phi is
representing a small vector and theta is
representing the majority of those
neural network parameters then in my
mind this is less of a restriction
because you can because it basically
it's okay for Phi to be Phi to be
Gaussian because if you could be
transformed by the neural network into a
more complicated distribution okay any
questions before we move on to
optimization based mode learning
okay so what about optimization based
model learning approaches so you might
say okay well we talked about this a
little bit a couple lectures ago where
there is this paper that kind of
recasted gradient based metal learning
as in France in this hierarchical
Bayesian model and this was nice and
then to provide a Bayesian
interpretation of mammal as as kind of
doing learning but meta parameters such
that you are such that a test time
you're doing map and friends under this
under a Gaussian prior represented by
your meta parameters so this is nice but
it isn't kind of what we set out for us
to be done in this lecture which is in
particular what it's doing is it's using
a map estimate of your task specific
parameters Phi as a function of theta
and I mean that it's representing a
point estimate of this distribution it's
only giving you one set of parameters
for this distribution and you can't
for example sample from this
distribution or you can't more easily
represent the full distribution of your
task parameters okay so how can we
develop approaches that actually allow
us to do that so one thing we could do
is build upon the they kind of what we
had derived before for black box model
learning where we have we're going to
use amortize variational inference we
have the subjective that corresponds to
the likelihood of the data plus/minus
skl term and in particular one thing you
could remember is that you can really be
any arbitrary function and in particular
what we did before is we had Q be a
black box that takes as input that it
has parameters theta and takes as input
a data set and output it's a set of
parameters but we'd also do other things
for Q for example Q could also include a
gradient operator and in particular so
you can have an inference Network that
is basically performing gradient descent
inside your inference Network because
who doesn't need to be a neural network
could be anything that outputs a
distribution over five
and so I'm pretty clear in this in this
paper what what this approach does is
they decide q2b SGD with respect to the
mean and variance of neural network
weights so we're gonna be running
gradient descent with respect to the
mean of a set of parameters and the
variance of the set of parameters with
respect to some training data and then
everything else is the same
and I'm pretty clear I guess one thing
that's worth mentioning is that in
contrast to things like mammal this is
not just running a gradient descent on a
parameters it's running grain descent on
the mean and the variance of the
parameters and that's such that you
actually out at the end of this
procedure you get both a mean and
variance of the parameter is not just I
mean okay so the benefit of this
approach is that you're you're running
gradient descent I test time and so we
we get an optimization based mental
learning approach by basically stuff in
gradient descent into your inference
Network and it's also it's quite simple
the downside is that you need to model
this distribution by even theta as a
cowman and the reason for that similar
to what I the same reason why we need to
do it for is the same reason for why we
need to do it in the black box case
which is that we need to be able to reap
ramit rise in order to backprop
gradients into queue and we need to be
able to evaluate the KL term that's on
the right and in in the case of
optimization base model learning this is
more of a problem because these are
actually gonna be representing the
parameters of our neural network okay so
can we model a non Gaussian posterior
with optimization based on learning
algorithms so one thing that we talked
about in terms of the kind of toolbox of
approaches is that we don't just have
there isn't just latent variable
inference there isn't toast variational
autoencoders we could also use something
like ensembles and so this is what Kim
had all did in 2018 the first kind of
basic version of the algorithm was to
just train em independent mammal models
you just run mammal on different subsets
of your data
then you get an ensemble of mammals uh
it's also worth noting that you can do
this with something other than mammal as
well you could do like it do an ensemble
black box models are not parametric
models and this is actually it's pretty
simple it actually works pretty well and
so if you want to like if you want it
kind of probably the simplest approach
for for getting a distribution over
models you could just trade it on sample
of things one downside of this approach
though is if you really care about
getting accurate distributions this
won't work well if your ensemble members
are too similar and sometimes if you
just train that works independently you
might end up with those models looking
fairly similar depending on some of the
implementation details of how you
initialize how how you sample the data
for each model and so what what the
others did in this paper is they show
that there's ways to make it more
diverse so in particular there is an
approach called Stein variational
gradient descent I'm what what it
basically does I don't want to get into
some of the - all the details but what
it basically does it pushes the
different ensemble members away from
each other to encourage them to
represent different models and the way
that you accomplish this is that you
have when you're running gradient
descent you have your typical likelihood
term but you also have a term that
encourages the different ensemble
members to be different from one another
and there's different different kernel
kernel like functions that you can do to
represent the similarity between models
okay
and so the result of this is you get a
more diverse ensemble of mammals okay
the other thing that they did I hear as
well is instead of just pushing the
particles away from one another they
also optimize such that the ensemble
gives you a distribution of particles
that produce high likelihood and so
instead of completely separately
training these different models
they took they're all basically they
took their ensemble and they optimized a
term that depends basically they
optimized them all jointly together so
you have if you have n particles you're
out you're optimizing for the likelihood
that's averaged over those M particles
okay so the benefits of this approach is
that it's simple and tends to work well
it also gives you non Gaussian
distributions which is quite nice
the downside is that in some instances
in some scenarios you may not want to
represent an M different sets of
parameters and this is something that
requires you to maintain instances of
your model dl3 said that one way to get
around this is to only do gradient based
in fronts on your last layer so you only
have to have M copies if the last layer
of your network rather than n copies up
the entire entire network although in
practice you may you may also want to be
able to represent distribution so for
all of your parameters not just over the
last layer okay so so far we talked
about how we can use amortized
variational inference and now we can use
ensembles there's one more approach that
I'll talk about here but any questions
on the ensemble's yeah so that's yes so
basically if you only did this this
right term they might just all kind of
collapse to a single point of high
likelihood and that's exactly what this
this left thing will do it'll try to
push them apart from each other such
that they represent they represent
different parts of the distribution okay
so is there a way to try to get it on
Gaussian posterior over all the
parameters without having to maintain
separate model instances so this last
approach that we'll talk about and in
particular what we'll try to do I guess
yeah I guess yeah oh yeah what we'll try
to do is we'll try to sample parameter
vectors a test time with a procedure
that looks like Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
alright and particular what Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo does is it adds noise and
then runs gradient descent repeatedly in
order to be able to sample from some
to be said and so particularly what
we'll want to do is if we have say we
have our example shown here where we
have this ambiguous situation what we
want to be able to do is learn a prior
such that a random kick in any direction
will put us in different modes of our
distribution so for example if this is
our our lost landscape and there's
different different kind of modes of
solutions one corresponds to a
classifier that classifies on smiling
and wearing a hat one that classifies on
smiling and being young we want
essentially a parameter vector here such
that if we add some noise to that
parameter vector and then run gradient
descent we get two different modes of
the solution we get different functions
that represent different we get
different functions that represent
different modes of that correct answer
okay so this is what we want to be able
to do at test time just add noise and
grind gradient descent the way that we
do this
so first let's play our graphical model
shown before in this case we're gonna
have data be a distribution so one one
nuance thing I didn't mention before is
before if we're just kind of putting
theta as parameters we're not actually
having a distribution over theta in this
case theta will no longer just be kind
of a single parameter vector that
parameterize those things it'll actually
be a distribution and then we'll also
have a set of also have our task
specific parameters given theta our goal
will be the sample different toss
Pacific parameters given all of our
observed variables at test time and the
things that we can observe a test time
our X train by train and X test okay
this is our just like our goal is from
before I guess one of the things to note
here first is that we can actually cross
out this term but because X test is
conditionally independent of Phi given Y
test or sorry when you're not given Y
test they are conditionally independent
or that you're not giving Y tests
they're independent
and so therefore we can we can ignore
this term and just model sample try to
sample from the function Phi given X
train and y train know if we try to
actually derive what this corresponds to
in this graphical model we get an
integral of the of P of theta times p fi
i given theta times our data given v
where we need to integrate out our prior
data okay
so unfortunately this is kind of the the
exact solution for this distribution but
of course this integral is completely
intractable and so what we're gonna say
i guess first as a side note is if we
knew so visitor from interval is
incomplete is is completely intractable
and so we have to do something different
one thing we're doing is if we knew this
distribution if we knew how to sample
Phi given theta x-ray and white rain
then sampling becomes a lot easier so we
if we knew this distribution then we can
just use ancestral sampling where we
first sample with theta and then we
sample from this distribution to be able
to sample from five and a pinko the
graphical model would look like this for
a first sample theta and then sample Phi
given there's three variables so if we
knew that distribution things would be
easy how do we get that distribution
well what we can do is we can use an
approximation similar to what was shown
in the paper by Grant at all which is
estimate this approximation crudely
using estimate this distribution crudely
using a point estimate four five and we
can approximate this using map inference
this is again extremely crude but it's
also extremely convenient which is that
if we can basically approximate this
with mouth map inference correspond to
running a few steps of gradient descent
then unlike the previous paper we can
still actually sample from five where we
first sample from theta then we run a
Yusuf's of green descent and then get
our model so this is what happens at
test time when we want to do inference
training is a bit more complicated but
it can be done with the tools that we've
mentioned before using amortized
variational inference so I'm not going
to go into how we do training but if
you're interested you can you can see
the paper
what ancestral sampling looks like is
basically exactly what we tried before
so first we sample we have our our
distribution we have new data
first we sample from Kiev data which has
a mean and a variance this corresponds
to starting from this mean variance
adding noise like the reprioritization
trick and then we run gradient descent
starting from that sample theta running
gradients is that with respect to our
data and that gives us into these types
of it allows us to represent these types
of multimodal distributions okay so the
benefit of this approach is that it
gives us a non graph in posterior it's
very simple at test time we can just add
noise and then run gradient descent and
we only have one instance of the model
the downside is that it has a more
complex training procedure and it also
has some some fairly crude
approximations that are in the in the
derivation okay
so that's it for methods to summarize we
talked about first a very simple method
which outputs a distribution over Y the
benefit of this is a simple you can
combine it with a variety of methods the
downside is that you can't reason about
uncertainty about the other like
function you have a limited class of
distributions over wide that you can
represent and in practice these methods
tend to produce uncertainty estimates
that are not very calibrated we also
talked about how we can use amortized
variational inference with black box
approaches where we can represent a non
Gaussian distributions over Y but only
option two situations over Phi which is
fine if Phi is a latent vector I know by
the last thing we talked about
optimization based approaches which I've
looked at you
advertised variational inference
ensembles and this sort of hybrid
inference procedure that I mentioned the
benefits of the amortized variational
inference was that it was simple but we
need to model the distribution over our
parameters as Gaussian ensembles allowed
us to use non Gaussian distributions at
the cost of maintaining em separate
models or doing inference on the last
layer and then the hybrid inference
approaches allowed us to represent non
Goshen posteriors with only a single
model instance with a more complex
training procedure any questions on
methods before I talk about evaluation
and what we can actually use these
methods for yeah yeah exactly so I guess
well so this is also a downside of
ensembles as well is we can only sample
we can't actually we don't we can't
analytically represent things like
entropy likelihood it's much more
difficult to represent those things we
can only sample but one thing you could
do is you can sample and then
empirically estimate like what was the
variance of my samples and we'll
actually see in a couple slides how
these methods actually work if you want
to estimate that sort of uncertainty
other questions
okay so how do we evaluate these methods
because these papers are relatively new
it I figured that kind of the way to
cover this was just to describe a number
of different ways for for effectively
evaluating these algorithms I guess the
first question is will commit to use
standard benchmarks can we use things
like mini imagenet to evaluate these
meta learning algorithms what do you
think what do you think are the kind of
pros and cons of using standard
benchmarks yeah
good yeah so the pro is that we can to
repeat the question for people who are
remote the Pro is that it corresponds to
something we care about the con is that
doesn't actually evaluate uncertainty
any other pros and cons
yeah yeah so a lot of algorithms have
already evaluated on this and so he may
be overfitting to these benchmarks it
may also be that they're yeah that the
yeah we're or if any of these certainly
anything else yeah yeah that's a good
point so in this example in many image
that there may not be that much
ambiguity in the underlying task it may
actually be there may be actually no
ambiguity and in the correct label given
the data set ok so here's some of the
things that I had down so one Pro is
that they're standardized and so it
makes it a little bit easier to compare
across across papers although in
practice some paper is d standardized it
by using different architectures using
different protocols another benefit is
that it has real images it's kind of a
very real problem it's also a good check
that your approach didn't break anything
if the if for example your projects
e-tanks on these benchmarks that means
that something is probably wrong the
downsides that I had written down is
that first metrics like accuracy don't
actually evaluate things like
uncertainty as was mentioned the tasks
don't may not actually exhibit that
ambiguity and lastly uncertainty may not
actually be that useful
on this data set ok so what are some
better problems and better metrics that
we can use
I guess we're finishing it kind of
really depends on the problem that you
care about how you measure how you
measure how good these algorithms are
and which problems to test on so we'll
cover some and these can maybe inspire
different applications so one very
simple way to try to look at these look
at the performance of these algorithms
is look at very toy examples so here's
an example from some of our prior work
although there's a number of other
methods that have also looked at very
toy examples where you can actually
visualize the underlying functions that
you're sampling from so the top example
corresponds to a class of the underlying
metal learning functions are both
sinusoids and linear functions where
there's noise and the labels to make the
task ambiguous and so you can see that
it I that kind of types of functions
that's reasoning about in some
situations it's ambiguous even if it's a
sinusoid function or a linear function
and you see this sort of multimodal
output from the sampling distribution
and that's something that's something
that's nice to see because it shows that
the function can actually represent
something that's multimodal and the
second example is a classification
example where you're just given one data
point all the the tasks correspond to
circular decision boundaries and you're
trying to classify between positive
points and negative points the d-train
only contains one negative point one
positive point and D test contains both
positive and negative data points and so
basically you get these different you
can see a visualization of the decision
boundaries here shown in that in the
dashed lines where the function is the
neural network is representing these
different decision boundaries that kind
of represent the structure of the class
of functions that it was trained on so
this is these are something things that
are kind of cool to look at and nice to
see although at the same time it's not
it's not a problem that we actually care
about so what are problems that we care
about a bit more so Gordon at all looked
at a task that correspond to generating
generative models from a few examples
and so there was in this case it was a
one-shot learning problem where the one
data point is shown on the left and the
goal is to generate examples to be able
to generate new examples of that object
instance and you can see that it's able
to as shown in the second row it's able
to generate new new instances and they
also looked at a quantitative evaluation
so in this case the qualitative
evaluation allows you to actually judge
the quality of the predictions to some
extent and the quantitative evaluation
allows you to look across the board
unfortunately these metrics mean squared
error and ssim actually aren't great
metrics for evaluating the kind of the
like whether or not this is actually
covering the distribution well and
accurately representing that
distribution but it does at least give
you a quantitative measure of the
performance on that dataset okay
another thing that we can look at is
things like likelihood or we can look at
a combination of accuracy as well as
coverage of the correctness of the
distribution that you care about and so
this is something that that we did
motivate by the example that I showed
before where you're given a training
dataset that corresponds with three
attributes and then you have test test
examples that you need to be able to
label that course that have only two of
those two of those attributes and you
can see that qualitatively that's able
to learn classifiers that classify on
only pairs of attributes rather than all
three attributes and then quantitatively
we can see also look at this both
accuracy and coverage in this case
coverage was measured by does it cover
the three possible modes of this
distribution and then lastly also
looking at average negative log
likelihood so what are the benefits of
this is that these tasks are actually
ambiguous and they're actually real
tasks the downside is that the
this has made may or may not look like
the toss that you actually care about
depending on your application okay
another example that I thought was
interesting is this paper by Ravi and
Beatson they were looking at they're
trying to look at how reliable are the
uncertainty estimates that you get from
different algorithms and so what they
applied is they plotted the confidence
of the predictor versus the accuracy of
the of the picture so on a set of
examples how well does its confidence
correlate with its accuracy on those
examples and in the ideal case you would
get something that exactly follows this
diagonal line and this is the ours is
representing the amortized approach that
I mentioned before probabilistic Mammal
was the third approach that I mentioned
that uses a hybrid inference and then
Mammal is something that doesn't have is
I
basically corresponds to the first
approach where you just output a
distribution over Y and they looked at
both these both these these diagrams as
well as looking at the overall accuracy
of these approaches and I think it's
important to keep in mind both of these
accuracies as well because it's it's
possible to do a lot better on these
diagrams while doing a lot worse on
accuracy for example as you become more
and more accurate it becomes harder to
estimate these your confidence about the
things that you're inaccurate about okay
and then the last example I like to give
is an active learning evaluation so
there were actually two papers that did
this one on a very toy regression domain
as well as one on mini image step and in
both experiments what the authors did is
they looked at can we sequential e
choose data points that we want labels
for and in particular the way that you
choose a data point that you want to
label for is the one that has the
maximum predictive entropy for that data
point and there's different ways to
measure predictive entropy based on
whether using an ensemble or whether or
not you're using a just kind of
providing samples from that distribution
but I guess what we see across the board
is that the these algorithms
probabilistic manual on left and the
ensemble methods on the right are able
to show an improvement by using either a
diverse ensemble or by representing
uncertainty at all in comparison to just
randomly sampling the data points with
Mammal okay so this is one of the nice
things about this example is it's
something that we may actually care
about in practice it's it's it's a
downstream application that's very
relevant for being able to learn from
fewer labels in this case we can
basically get higher accuracy with fewer
queries the downside is that maybe maybe
active learning on sinusoid or image
that is not the thing that we ultimately
care about we may want to do an active
learning setting on a downstream
application that we where the amount of
data is much more sparse okay so trap up
we now talked about how we can reason
about uncertainty during learning and
meddler and such that
then learning the way that those
uncertainty estimates are something that
are actually valid and correct
next time on Wednesday we'll see how we
can look at meta learning for active
learning as well as medal earning for
unsupervised learning semi-supervised
learning and weekly supervised learning
but I think are actually some pretty
cool ways to think about these types of
problems and then on Monday we'll start
talking about reinforcement learning
great so so reminder is homework 2 is
due next week project proposal is due in
two weeks and poster presentation is
fixed I'll see you all on Wednesday